tout commence par un petit coup de jus
dans la rivière les poissons anesthésié
peuvent ainsi être capturés avant d'être
équipé un art d'un petit émetteur
on fait une petite incision sur le
poisson de 1,5 à 2 mm et ensuite on
insère le tac dans la cavité abdominale
on reprend un peu de mucus pour aider à
cicatriser par la suite et on les remet
aux pannes de réveil et après les
poissons ce pour lâcher un peu plus en
aval des truites des chevesnes des
chabots en tout 250 poissons sont
équipées du dispositif
l'objectif voir s'ils arrivent à
remonter la passe à poissons juste au
dessus un point noir dans la circulation
de la fecht une passe qui a été
construite dans les années 95 et qui a
diagnostiqué à l'heure actuelle
difficilement franchissable donc on fait
un suivi pour avoir un état initial donc
on a des antennes placées à laval du
seuil à l'entrée de la passe et à la
sortie de la passe donc ils vont
détecter chaque fois sont marqués et qui
permet d'évaluer les difficultés de
franchissement de la passe par
l'équation tous les ans dans le haut
rhin 4 à 5 passes à poissons difficile à
franchir font l'objet de gros travaux de
rénovation comme ici à wihr-au-val un
vaste programme de restauration
écologique des cours d'eau pour peut
toujours élever des poissons en
pisciculture à les jeter dans la rivière
quand même c'est pas ça le développement
durable des poissons et se débrouille
très bien sans nous et celui des laissez
passer les ouvrages et qui trouve les
endroits où ils peuvent se nourrir se
reproduire la libre circulation est un
enjeu majeur pour l'environnement les
truites notamment doivent pouvoir
remonter les rivières pour survivre